all right good evening let's make a
start like to welcome you all to
tonight's meeting of the Clara committee
a my name's Danny Kendall I'll be here
cheering tonight's meeting in accordance
with the rules and procedures are set
out on the inside front cover of your
agenda tonight before we get started if
I can just remind em to the public that
the meeting is being recorded and will
be available for you to review at your
leisure on YouTube thank you and good
evening chair I just wanted to highlight
with the first application
site is situated immediately behind our
offices but I don't believe this it
doesn't have any impact and as an estate
agent were not involved in the marketing
of the properties at all but I just
wanted to highlight no objection
representation so I'll be standing down
Thank You counsel Dixon the same goes
for myself but I would have anticipated
that essentially one could still come to
this committee with a clear mind in
order to be persuaded one way or the
other
item number seven 1901 five nine four on
the ward members and I'll be speaking on
that and item number seven 1902 four
nine one LBC in 1902 seven zero zero I'm
the applicant of myself right that's all
declarations interest you right in that
case we've moved to our first item on
the agenda tonight which is item four
found on page fifteen agendas this is
nineteen slash zero one eight Millstreet
counting no description proposed I'll
give you the smaller to modify the
housing mix introduced gas tanks and
change block ten carport and other
design changes Joe thank you the Saudis
located in the physical confines and
content as indicated by the black dot
before you the application site itself
is situated at core closed Mill Street
runs parallel to the northern and
eastern bounces of solid of which the
existing rear gardens of the two-story
Reverend Williams withdrawn the site's
boundary so so sorry for Easter so it is
a mixture of residential and commercial
properties which front on bamboo street
and so from Street respectively the
application site is also located
adjacent to but just beyond the Contin
Conservation Area boundary so this is
and so firm Street rundown commercial
properties
best dancers just in 2018 under
applications 17 slap stereo 3 782 full
piling permission was granted for the
demolition of the dwelling and erection
of attend new dwellings a mix of
bungalows and houses approved site
access publication space and associated
landscaping furthermore application 1900
496 very committed a number of external
design alterations as well as
modification to housing mix this
application is fundamentally seeking
permission for the installation the gas
tanks in station solar panels internal
alterations and some associate external
alterations additional windows mainly
and it's in the carport to plot 10 okay
the plan before you it shows one of the
representatives of the bungalows that
I've been approved is currently under
construction as you can see the
difference mainly on this is PV panels
application this is one or two stories
it's also this is a landscaping scheme
as you can see in open space and
greenery which does have a section 106
for its maintenance in keeping it open
to the public
this is the area that is within the open
space so you can see the green where the
LPG gas tanks are proposed
and these are photos taken today so
these are almost up to date as you can
see the iris and the dwellings are
already going up the PV panels
associated on some of the roof in this
is the middle of the site existing
dwellings along Mill Street
he's recommended the condition 10 is
update it to also include the removal
apart so you cast APD rights to control
the means of enclosure in the public
open space you will also know on the
update sheet there is various amendments
I've come through since the report was
done motion more Mario in detail over
all in conclusion fundamentally the two
main differences to that which has
already been approved by the
installation of the PV panels which are
considered not to cause any harm in
terms of appearance or impact on the
character of the area and the
installation of the gas tanks which are
considered also not to cause any harm in
terms of appearance and all landscape
and also consider to be acceptable in
terms the impact on the open space area
thank you
actually corrected things that have
happened since the original planning was
granted which was remove the trees
carefully use the word indicative
drawing to show those gas tanks there
are no section drawings that show just
how much the public open space may cease
to be a flat and unusable public open
space it's difficult to judge I accept
that photograph that you can see as I
say it's difficult to judge it in
relation to the ground level of the
footpath has just been put in but the
top of those gas tanks and the access
traps for delivering gas on the face of
it that's quite significantly above
standard ground level and if I can have
the second photograph please this is
another development nearby where you can
just see two gas tank blades and you can
see some above ground equipment there is
an email reassurance that there is no
requirement for such equipment on call
close despite the fact that it's four
more houses I fully accept that building
regulations are not an issue for
planning nevertheless our attempts to
try and make sure that
building regulations have been complied
with for these gas tank installations
given the close proximity of those tanks
to the neighboring properties has not
been possible and we were advised to
contact Callaghan we is the parish
council were advised to contact colour
gas to get proper details and we haven't
been able to do that I can tell you that
it's the opinion of the building control
officer of this district council that it
doesn't meet the approved document for
building regulations in terms of safety
in siting of these tanks because they
are large and buried and I accept the
building regulations isn't relevant but
there's a section in Joe's report where
it says that the gas is required despite
all of our desires to reduce carbon
footprint the gas is required because
building regulations call for all
properties to have a supply other than
just electricity and if that was the
case 10 seconds if that was the case how
come there are 10 houses being built in
little Kyneton with only electricity
supply I believe that there are some
sort of contradictory facts being put
about thank you
Thank You councillor questions from the
committee
councillor Perry thank you good evening
Council Gosling can you advise if
there's been any engagement with the
parish council regarding these
particular changes in view of the
potential impact as you highlight
regarding the public open space
particularly with regard to the public
open space none other than has been
responded to the planning officer as
we've raised issues and put them forward
as objections but the applicant hasn't
engaged with you separately the
applicant engage with us on on the very
first variation but that was
particularly due to the change of house
styles okay any further questions from
the committee
know which case council thank you very
much thank you thank you get our next
speaker Miranda Rogers and piers Harding
please the agent and applicant
respectively welcome bones I think
you've been here before so you know the
routine keep remain seated for any
questions at the end and I'll give you a
10-second warning if that's all right
good evening right this variation is
taking a number of changes minor
building changes appear on controversial
and warrant no further comments but
there are two more significant changes
which required to ensure the provision
of heating and electricity to the
dwellings firstly electricity this
variation is proposing the installation
of solar panels to each dwelling
providing power for cooking and lighting
offered to enhance the sustainability of
the development any surplus electricity
generated will be returned to the
National Grid and secondly heating mains
gas is used to heat the vast majority of
new houses in the district unfortunately
it's not available in the center of
Kyneton instead it was always envisaged
that gas tanks positioned under the
public open space would be used their
provision is acknowledged and catered
for in the section 106 so why gas tanks
realistically there isn't an alternative
air source heat pumps are noisy and
harmful to residential amenity oil has
poor sustainability credentials there's
insufficient land available to use
ground source heat pumps and the
building regs we needed to comply with
wouldn't allow us to have an entirely
electric heating system to gas tanks
have been partially installed you've
seen the pictures the system will work
initially using LPG gas but is also bio
LPG ready bio LPG is a non fossil plant
based renewable energy form any carbon
dioxide created is largely offset by
that absorbed by the plant growth stage
effectively making it carbon neutral
LPG is available now and as soon as the
building recs have caught up with it it
will be replaced as traditional LPG on
gas at this site the parish council has
commented that the gas tanks will
sterilize or may sterilize part of the
open space we don't believe that's true
we've been out today and done the
measurements with the theodolite and
when it's complete all that will be left
will be the manhole cover the public
open space will be contoured and the
grass running right up to that manhole
the height variation across the public
open space is about 13 inches just over
a foot
the limited slope will add interest in
the landscape area and leave it entirely
usable by all and no there won't be a
green box finally the Parish Council has
raised concerns about installation of
the tanks and respect of building
regulations the installation has been
overseen by Nigel Parkinson the approved
building inspector who has confirmed the
relevant standards and approved document
J have been met so to conclude the
proposed building design changes will
enhance the appearance of the site this
game proposes enhancements to
sustainability solar power for
electricity and bio LPG ready gas tanks
for heating together these reduce carbon
dioxide emissions and minimize impact on
the environment in accordance with core
strategy policy CS do all I can ask is
that you thank you
any questions yes councillor Jenny
mentioned not taking down some trees it
is unfortunate that a couple of trees
were taken out as part of the the early
phases and they were updated on the new
landscaping plan and replacement trees
put in to take a moment thank you
Calipari then councillor band good
evening you could we were shown some
pictures by the parish council of when
you talk about the contours of the
public open space I mean
I just want if you could just give a bit
more background into the type of public
open space and is that going to be any
any equipment or anything else on it
bearing in mind that you've got
bungalows on the site it's obviously
appealing to you're expecting to have
some more mature P I'm just want to have
an understanding of the usability of the
public open space if the gas tanks are
at a fairly high level I know you
mentioned 13 inches but on the basis of
the pictures that were shown are the
tanks going to be are they just being
positioned in place and will be
submerged further down or are we going
to have sweeping banks raising up to
them so that the level I'm interested to
know what the level is from the footpath
that we saw there up to the top of the
green manhole lives from LPG the
measurement I gave you is from what will
be the top of the footpath what you can
see in that picture is the base level
only the footpath isn't complete you
have to bear in mind when you look at
the tanks that obviously the top
someone's being taken off and what will
happen is the top soil will go back and
then it will be planted over the top so
it will be grasped the there is a
landscaping plan that's already been
approved through discharge of conditions
it is almost identical to the one that
you've got for this application and it
includes planting around the edges and a
grass area with some wildflower planting
in it so it is it is intended to be only
a grass area that people walk through
there's no play equipment or other
equipment if I could just come back you
talked about it being a grassed area
that people can walk over if there is I
still would like a bit more information
about the sloping in the contours or is
it is it just a green area that people
can look at is it being designed more
for people to feel there's a sense of
open space but not actually walk on B
I'm just concerned about the various
contours that if
13 inches okay so that's the contour
right public open space is 30 meters
along and between the foot so it's that
much higher than the footpaths that much
higher than the final level of the
footpath the public open space which you
can see on the plan in front of you from
left to right is 30 meters and can you
just zoom in you can see the road to the
to the north of the red line you can see
the footpath that runs through the
northern part of the public open space
so from the southern part of the
footpath to the to the front of the you
can see where the front of the houses
are and then there's a footpath in front
of that that's about nine and a half ten
meters so we've got 30 metres by 10
meters of grass area and yes you will
get a mound in it that will go up by
that much so it is just over a foot it's
a very gentle gradual slope and people
will be able to use that open space
that's the entire intention of it the
idea is that has no foot path that runs
down that road so people are being
encouraged to come into the site on that
footpath and walk through as they go
from the village centre through to the
public community spaces at the back so
it's supposed to be an area which is
usable okay they're above the ground at
the moment because the topsoil has all
been stripped off and once that's put
back in the grasses but back and there's
a very gentle slope it will rise back up
again I mean even if those tanks weren't
there that is not the finished level for
the fairways
the survey has been out today and
measured the exact heights because we
knew this was likely to be an issue that
was raised and yeah 13 inches maximum
okay yes counselor Adam just briefly in
terms of refilling the tanks what sort
of equipment will be needed for that if
are we going to be tracking plant across
the green area it is a single vehicle
that will park on the road outside it
takes about 20 minutes and they have a
pipe that runs across them and it's
taken away again so there'll be no
vehicles on there big open space
Chancellor Dixon you mentioned that
ground source heat pumps were most
appropriate because there was
insufficient land my recollection is
that there can be both horizontal and
vertical down might be more expensive we
didn't see the LPG being controversial
especially with the bio LPG which would
be very keen to ensure that the
installation will be potentials that way
I think I'll just one final question
looking back through the history of this
site the application process seems
rather disjointed would you agree that
this does not necessarily reflect good
planting practice to put on putting
continual applications for a site at
this size I think we have worked
incredibly hard to get a result that
we've had so I've been involved with
this right from the day that the site
was brought to the attention of the
owners they came to me we spoke to the
parish council what three times before
the first application went in there
objection was landscape
and highways related only the
application took a very long time to get
through because we were trying to get
the legal agreements sorted I put in the
first variate variation application in
February and by May when the case office
had changed I was told there were no
objections to it and it would go through
with no problems but we needed to change
something in the legal agreement that
legal agreement was finally signed in
towards the end of November so it took
from May to November and the need for
the LPG tanks to go in it was understood
they were going to be committee
development but unfortunate we had to
put two in rather than one which
required the application process the
application went in back in the summer
we delayed them to late because we
wanted to get the first variation
through before we put the second one in
so that they were dealt with one and
then the other but in the end because of
this development as you've seen from
pictures there are there are people
waiting to move in next month and we
ended up having to put in the second
variation application at the same time
yes there have been other minor
modifications have gone in through the
process as purchasers have come on board
and say I'd like to buy this plot can we
make this change in this tweak and we've
because we've had applications in we've
been able to do it but the delays
unfortunately have not been so knee down
to us fair enough that's okay I just
wonder what your thoughts are in that
case don't worry thank you for your time
thank you all right Gareth final speaker
and her one member council Mills
welcome counselor Mills well you know
the routine you've got five minutes I'm
afraid mr. chairman this will not even
take good evening committee once again
we have an application which is as far
as I can see goes against the original
plans submitted by the developer this
application before you is yet another
alteration to the original plans for
this site for example or several
examples we've had trees cut down she
was shown original plans to bed retail
there's one bungalow which when compared
to original plans has been built at the
wrong place as the separation distances
from then Jason insisting house clearly
shows this the configuration of the
bungalow had been changed and now has a
window looking directly into a business
house the roof line on this bungalow had
to be changed you're in construction
because she had to gain the developer
had in mind in mind was trying to get
away with not a Deering to the plans
even the waste collection points of this
site are not set on the plans you may
say there's nothing to do with the
application in front of you this evening
but it does show how Cavalier the
developers are approach has been towards
this site if it wasn't for the king
parish councils that I I'm sure you
wouldn't see another act an acceptable
site of a new development accountant as
you can see by the update she that'd be
more retrospective applications as joe
said there must be mine I indeed oh but
they are even more amendments so the
application be here before you tonight
demonstrated how yet again the
developers are trying on trying it on
one for a better at the phrase the gas
tanks were not part of regional plans
and the placement of gas tanks will
detract from the green open space as a
peek Harry would no longer be flat the
application shows complete disregard to
original plans and in my mind should be
refused Thank You mr. chairman
that kick-out smells any questions for
the water member in that case thank you
very much to me thank you right
what's clarification from the committee
Chancellor Perry yeah can we just have
officer confirmation in terms of the
location of the LPG gas tanks in
relation to the dwellings that they are
in the optimum optimum place in terms of
size because there was concern raised by
the parish council about the safety
issue in terms of planning that is where
they are going in the process the only
thing that will be visible above ground
will be the manhole cover and the green
manhole cover and in terms of optical
health and safety
[Music]
that's correct councilor the Health and
Safety Executive managed the health and
safety of the site and therefore it's
not a to consideration because all right
any other questions yes counselor
regarding the original application what
was the alternative energy source
thought about which is clearly an issue
for choosing this source now the
original application and the other very
that's been approved the energy source
was simply electricity they didn't have
PV panels and he didn't have the LPG gas
tanks and that is what has been improved
so far is where's the requirement for a
multiple
energy sources come from that's relevant
now when I walk into in the road in
accordance with building regulations
most heard by the age and they during
the course of development from my
understanding of realized they can't
meet up building regulations electricity
solely so they've had to find a little
sauce
the suit was source being LPG gas tanks
they've stated the reasons why they've
not gone down oil or the Embassy's right
there are no more clarification points
go to the debate counselor Jenny's
encounters Tariq said all right why
didn't they just dig a bit deeper it's
at that point but I suppose we've got to
judge the application before us rather
than I wish list that's the parry Thank
You chair well first of all I have quite
a bit of sympathy for the parish council
in the world member review the number of
variations and the tooling and froing
however from an applicant's point of
view there's obviously been a number of
challenges based on getting the legal
side corrected etc however based based
on the application that we have in front
of us there in there is no significant
harm being caused by this variation and
I can't see a valid planning reason to
refuse this so I will be going with the
officers recommendation but I just would
like it noted that I do have every
sympathy with the parish council because
there's nothing more frustrating than in
a central village location hi
profile to have it keep coming back so
that those are my views yeah completely
agree with you actually
concerns the parish council was that
these amendments like quite often had
been done you know and then they come
back but they disappear that the company
are doing them properly my concern it
was a gas taxes I think realistic and
it's it's okay and I'm not so as far as
I'm concerned I'm quite happy to second
the recommendation proposal yet actually
but where you proposed yes
council Adam here is simply to to to
mirror councillor Perry's comments on on
the sentiment behind supporting the the
parish council and I would hope that the
the applicant considers that when the
on-the-ground aspect of the construction
industry okay thank you
I think I have my thoughts which is
exactly that I mean as a member of
parish council when you have these
larger sites coming to you over all time
and you keep on getting faced with
variation after variation it's very very
difficult but I mean especially parish
councils all volunteers all got busy
lives so they Dennis it's difficult to
see the differences sometimes and it
leaves what does it leads to changes
happening little by little and it's
incredibly frustrating so while I except
for the you know it wasn't all in your
control it's just frustrating from the
parish council sometimes but there we
are we've all said what we need to say
we've got a proposition and it's been
seconded that we go with the
recommendation to grant
we'll have to vote all those in favor
thank you okay in that case the
committee results to grant application
reference 19 / 0 1 8 & 7 0 / very we can
move to item 5 on tonight's agenda she
found on page 25 of agenda tonight
application reference and 19 / 0 1 5 9 4
/ ful 26 crooks Lane stubbly
and it's for the demolition of existing
dwelling and direction of 2
semi-detached houses presenting officer
miss your party it's Joe if you're ready
over to you Thank You chairman good
evening
this applications slide on screen shows
the application site by 30th black dots
plum plum Center almost within the
village of studly here we see some
satellite imagery of the application
sites one can see the site where it's
nestled in the builds barrier boundary
here we have an existing site plan of
Versailles and its current guys long
considered dwelling recently approved
here that is within the land ownership
of the applicant fee application this
evening signified by the blue line on
the plan here we now have the proposed
site layouts one can also see somewhat
faintly but hopefully you can see a
dotted line signaling where the existing
dwelling is proposed to be demolished in
relation to whether and proposed two
dwelling is false it's being bought as
it's closer to the public highway here
we have opposed elevations and street
scene plan one can see again a dotted
line here on the bottom showing the
outline of the existing dwelling as is
one could see v2 semi-detached dwellings
here and then one or two cv already
approved single detached dwelling made
and one can see there is a somewhat
uniform rich height and indeed this
these two dwellings are actually set
lower than the already existing
neighboring property to the north here
we are now some photos of the sights
here we're now stood on the existing
vehicle access points looking at the
dwelling proposed to be demolished and
the garage building here immediately in
the foreground and slightly different
angle now looking northeast words at the
dwelling deposed to be demolished to
give you some indication this is the
dwelling that I was referring to a
moment ago that's that was recently
approved again within the applicants
ownership moxie that's been
substantially completed at the time of
offices site visits the creation of this
edition of dwelling is considered to be
acceptable in this highly sustainable
location and it's considered to improve
the quality of the housing stock that's
current on site harmonizing with
immediate surrounding built form and
creating a more legible uniform building
line officers recognize the importance
of both highway and pedestrian safety in
addition to naming and melody concerns
and it was for this reason offices
requested the Yap can provide a
construction management plan at the
initial validation stage where it
normally it might be requested by
condition chairman the recommendation is
to grant for the reason six out pages 31
of your agenda Thank You councillor
Beeman snuggly parish council
welcome counselor I think you probably
know the routine three minutes for any
questions
welcome yes
this site is right in the middle of the
village is the officers pointed out and
that is probably where the problem is
this footpath that runs across the front
area says most of the pedestrian traffic
for the local schools 700 at the high
school 250 at one 250 to another 300 so
some thin over a thousand children
walking backwards and forwards those
that come back are and most of them are
using this footpath one way or another
every morning every afternoon and that
is the parish councils concern the
development on the site we have no
issues with the applicant has actually
worked and amended the original design
to something is more suitable the
problem we have is the tandem parking we
see that as an issue with people
reversing off drives when there's
potential for kids walking across those
drives which won't be seen very well
there's a lot of parking takes place all
the way along that road so it's
difficult to see what's coming up and
down traffic and we see they've been a
real conflict and a problem if the
properties were pushed back a little bit
and widened you could get two parking
spaces in front of each one without too
much of a problem in its present form we
don't think that it's safe for the
children that we're walking on down
there and that is the main reason the
parish council objection we think that
no issue with the development here it is
just the the layout with the parking
that is what we'd like to see changed
thank you any questions for the parish
council council dictum may be born given
your local knowledge of that street are
most of the properties of on dev with
cars etc able to always exit their
properties in forward gear the majority
of the properties along there have
either long drives where they can get in
turn in on the front or they
almost parallel with the curb so they
can drive in and the issue we have is
when you've got tandem parking you've
got the option where somebody's always
going to come off and pull and then
another one come out behind and that's
where we think the conflict will come
and we can't see anywhere else along
there where we have a similar sort of
situation any other questions for parish
council no that case Council thank you
very much for your time and thank you
Thank You agent for the applicant mr.
Gary Phillips please welcome so same
rules play have three minutes if you'd
remain seated for any questions should I
give you the warning at ten seconds let
you know to wrap up thank you very much
mr. speaker
we've worked very hard with officers to
effectively try and reach a compromise
on this development has been advised in
the officers report the actual footprint
of the to dwell in Z is very similar to
the existing one and obviously by
position in the new proposed dwelling
sort of forward following the actual
existing building line of the garage to
the north which is shown very faintly on
the the plan actually on the screen now
and also by following the new dwelling
to the South it's possible obviously now
to create much more space to the rear of
the property for amenity Council of
Beeman's comments a relation to parking
there is an improvement in the parking
situation over sorry there is an exist
an improvement in the existing situation
in that where the garage is at the
moment to the north you care to park in
front of that garage and you would be
far closer to the football so there is a
couple of metres
behind each tandem set of parking spaces
to the back of the footpath in addition
those parking spaces are away from the
access which is quite tight to the
properties that are actually accessed to
the rear of the site so there is an
improved visibility to those properties
created by this new development and by
removal of that garage to the existing
condition which is a very important
consideration there are other properties
that are tandem parked along there and
obviously the adjacent property recently
approved also has tandem parking thank
you very much
based on the officers report and the
size i had original problems with the
overdevelopment at the site but
obviously the maths doesn't stack up and
that anymore so thank you for that I
would like to echo Paul's comments about
the tandem parking and the crossing of
the road and the situation around the
schools that is a real concern to me I
actually have the great pleasure of
having a tandem parking on the back of
my property and must express the fun and
games that I have if I'm the only driver
trying to get one car off to get the car
that's at the back of the tandem parking
you've got to find somewhere to park
you've got a jump out there's a good
deal of maneuvering that needs to be
done all of this along potentially busy
road the children running around or
indeed running around but also on bikes
and the like as well as in the rush hour
when we've got buses going along there
and the numerous cars dropping off
effectively on very much echoing
councillor Beeman's comments that really
is the tandem parking I have the biggest
problem with based on the fact of its
local location and the school so
effectively that's my argument so I'd
like you to consider also section O 2 of
our adopted development requirements
takes a negative view on tandem parking
and whilst I appreciate the applicants
comments just now about that there are
is some existing tandem parking in the
area this is a new build so I think we
need to give that some weight as well
thank you very much any questions to our
one member know the case thank you very
much right points for clarification
counsel Dixon obviously from the report
we can see that all the concerns
regarding tandem garage and parking etc
mr. Flaherty could express his opinions
on that because obviously during his
presentation I didn't catch anything to
address the tandem parking by way of
explanation because essentially I'm
thinking there might be more space at
the back could the garages could be
further back could we actually create on
that size plot an opportunity for cars
to leave in a forward gear because it's
a subjective viewpoint and you know this
is a do you have a specific question or
rather than just seeing if we could
redevelop at the side because we we
shouldn't really do that because we have
to look at what's there in front of us
not like that we have we have to look
what so that I've agreed to have to look
what's there in front of us but if the
concerns could be addressed such that if
in the planners opinions it could be a
situation whereby cars can leave in a
forward gear we should be requiring that
I think any discussion
parking arrange with when you going
through the application advice with the
applicant there was I would say I would
also say I can only echo some of the
church mentioned clearly the first
instance we can only consider the plans
are put before us and this is the case
currently as is commonplace obviously
I've consulted with County highways and
highway specialists who do with matters
of parking parking standards
forward-facing gear forward gears and
whatnot they offered no objection and
suggested two conditions to potentially
mitigate and and demon or accepts or but
on the specific tandem parking element
we didn't receive a anything in the way
of an objection in that respect I would
also just add yeah we can potentially go
down the road of trying to redesign this
for for-4 in applicants I would say the
gardens have been increased by virtue of
being the properties further forward if
you go down the road potentially looking
to move properties further back you're
reducing the depth the garden reducing
the minimum space that would make this
function at sustainable home
you've also decreasing the separation
distance to number 24 bring it further
back so all of this weighs in the plan
offices balance mower consider miss
unguided I'll go back to be to myself
why was it consulted with County
highways and we were satisfied that
there is no highways or parking
objection in that respect obviously I've
come across situations where the county
or officers have at least indicated that
they vehicles must leave in forward gear
is it your experience that this only
applies partially on a road or Abbey
Road and never on as it were these
limited streets
reverse parking can apply anywhere even
a road to have people reversed
what it would say and I'm not sure I'm
sure this is wade in in Stuart's mind
when assessing it it's not an unusual
urban situation to have people reversing
across the pavement onto a road
obviously it needs to be borne in mind
that the schools nearby there's always
going to be a risk you can't eliminate
risks you can only reduce it and I would
say that traffic speeds are slow any
children walking along there will also
be walking past many entrances where
reversing can take place so that that
needs to be borne in mind and therefore
what you need to consider is are these
additional accesses in this format so
much more harmful than the existing I
think one of the concerns around the
mitigation of risk is visibility in
terms of this type of parking
arrangement the scope of visibility onto
those parking spaces from the pavement
is that considered in the application
especially as I noticed the boundary as
it shown extends along the road and I
think some of the photos showed some
hedgerow along the front of the
neighboring property and that has been
factored into the assessment and
considered accordingly the reason the
the length of the visibility displays is
fairly standard place measurement
requirements and based on the manual for
streets this is a 30 mile an hour road
so this is something that highways would
have counter highways of sorts in
offices but it's a lot likewise so
that's that's in four part for
assessments meeting - except for one
that respect are there any restrictions
that would be put in place to ensure
that that's maintained but for instance
making sure that there aren't hedgerows
that might restrict visibility into the
future
now having consulted the County Highway
Authority they've not recommended any
visibility splays obviously as you'll be
aware they do sometimes recommend them
but in this case Thank You chair first
of all I think I'd like to thank the
parish council and the board member for
identifying potential risks I think it's
really important that we take obviously
pedestrian usage and but but the issue
we have here is that we have an
objection from highways we have
absolutely no grounds to refuse this in
my perspective on the grounds of
highways no objection and therefore I
propose that we go with the officers
recommendation of grant because if this
went to appeal it would just be turned
over by the planning inspector Thank You
counsel gentleman just echoes exactly
what I was about to say Oh in attendant
parking isn't ideal but I always have no
objections and I can see no valid
planning reasons to objectors so I was
quite happy just I can do I don't love
this at all and has the proud owner of
tendon party parking myself read on yeah
it's a it's a headache isn't it to be
honest having said that in terms of
safety I don't tend to reverse off my
tandem driveway at speed I tend to move
quite slowly so if there are children
passing along
I should sure I don't think it'd be
quite as dangerous as we think and
especially given a lot of houses along
there as well and finally I've got a
rostrum attention of course that next
door has recently been approved with
tandem parking you know the precedent
being set in terms of being allowed
along so I can't find any reason not to
go with the office recommendation so
everything's been said I think how do we
if everyone's happy should we go to the
vote been proposed when it's seconded
all those in favor please show okay in
that case the committee resolves to
grant application reference 19 slash
zero one five by four slash ful we can
go to our next item okay this is
application reference 1919 slash 0 2 1 3
9 / ful this is Caulfield's tan with
lane handling up this for the
subdivision of existing house and two
semi-detached dwellings presenting
officer issue of light again is Joe back
to you
Thank You chairman this application site
resides with an open countryside
location outside of the confines of
Australian villages as indicated by this
black dots on the screen here we see
satellite imagery of the application
site one can see the existing core
fields property here in addition to a
public right-of-way that runs here
approximately 50 meters or so to the
west of the property what can also see a
run of five dwellings immediately
opposite application site here with a
further sick of dwelling there and a
farmstead to the rear here we have the
submitted location plan of a site one
can see the proximity of the river on
which runs to the
north and east out the site the
application so it is also entirely
within the West Midlands Greenbelt
conditions being within a designated
special landscape area here we have the
proposed ground floor plans as submitted
simply just showing signifying the
subdivision of an existing dwelling and
likewise we have the proposed first
floor we now have some photos of the
site here we have stood on the public
highway looking northwards I'd say what
is a fairly Clements view of the
dwelling here we are now stood on the
actual front drive itself obviously with
the far more illuminating view the
extent of the external iterations for
the scheme comprise the removal of this
window here and the creation of what
would be a front door and a porch for
the separate dwelling here we're now
stood in the existing regard and looking
southwards at the rear elevation here we
are now stood on the public highway
immediately opposite the vehicle access
for the application sites looking at one
of the neighboring properties opposite
and likewise we're now stood a little
bit further down the highway looking at
a smattering of the other dwellings that
immediately opposite the application
site development does not meet any of
the residential provisions within the
develop an and a clear contravention of
the policy has been identified with this
the proposal is deemed to not be
acceptable in Princeville the
application site is not deemed to
qualify as an isolated location into the
property meteo buildings and is not
qualified to be assessed under national
plane policy in this regard the creation
of a dwelling in this location is deemed
to be an unsustainable location whereby
future occupants would not be able to
access services and would be solely
reliant on a private and vehicle
transport chairman the recommendation is
to refuse this application for the
reasons that pages 42 of your agenda
thank you thank you okay good our first
speaker on this one councillor Phil
kennings
from Allen Hall Parish Council
welcome counselor and thanks for waiting
right so you have three minutes if you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end give you a warning
you know your last 10 seconds if that's
okay over to you
good evening committee and counselors
that's my first time at planning
committee so pardon me if I'm still a
little bit we discuss it at parish
council the the applicant in question we
believe that the development would be
beneficial for her in terms of a smaller
property downsizing and enabling the
applicant to remain in her own home and
it would be a more manageable property
for for the applicant it's a sizeable
properties you can see by the the
pictures and the other thing near the
commenter would make is that any of the
the works traffic the site traffic
wouldn't impede on any of the adjoining
properties as the frontage is very
substantial so I don't think they're
being much effectively the adjoining
properties I did notice well by the
applications rather than words any
objections
apart from council flashes the the other
point we agreed on was the creation of
the additional property would most
likely benefit a family moving into the
area
this will also benefit the applicant in
terms of having their neighbors close
neighbors and I believe the applicant
lives there on their own Stein correct I
love them an older residents who I
believe would benefit from having a
family living next door so that's
basically what we agreed
thank you very much do you have any
questions for the parish council
counselor Perry hello good evening
um the parish carried out a housing
needs survey at all
in recent years not more knowledge I
only joined the parish council in July
so a neighborhood plan all that all it
is though neighborhood plan doing
through I appreciate the parish is quite
small so you haven't carried out a house
you need survey to identify what
potential local need might be no and
thank you yes council Adam do you know
if there's any other recent development
in the area in terms of housing
development has gone up in the recent
years just for the background knowledge
of the local area no certainly in the
vicinity just press it once in the
middle
it seems that oh you know there's not an
uncertainly in in the vicinity of core
fields there's there's no new
development at all and that was you know
that was you the point we agreed on that
it doesn't increase the footprint of the
of the site
it's a subdivision of an existing
substantial dwelling and the impact mind
reading any other questions from the
committee tonight in that case Council
thank you very much for your time thank
you thank you definitely right okay we
go to the points of clarification then
any questions councillor Perry yes I was
just interested to know that if if a
housing needs survey had been done and
this application came forward with a
local needs
and this hasn't been attached to
anything local needs I'm just trying to
find I was trying to look at a s10 in
terms of countryside and villages just
to see would I just want clarification
on that if if I know we're only looking
at what is in front of us but if this
application had an emphasis with local
needs Thank You counsel I have briefly
addressed that point laughing on page 38
of your agenda I have made obviously
I've gone through blow-by-blow the
different criteria for a s10 there's a
paragraph the pronounceable craft for
the bottom of the page whereby there is
certain provisions potentially where if
it was put forward as a local housing
needs scheme that might be different I
wish to sound like a broken record for
the last application we can only assess
what's put before us
think that except it book for us so we
can notice it and what's been put
forward thank you the simple reason is
we do development in the green belt the
small development part yeah I've got the
exact stickers for you but you can see
on the split there on your screen on the
on the screen rather it's approximately
at 50/50 split so I would say between
what is County they're what's being
proposed this is a really finely
balanced for house I really found it
difficult to make up my mind I could go
either way on it but I think sure you've
just clarified by thinking a little bit
for me there just isn't a reason to go
for it
I can't I mean it's against policy for
us and I'm not finding any extenuating
circumstance I'm not finding any nice
accounts of parents point out any house
in need I can't find a reason to go
against our Principality on this one so
I have to go with the officers of
recommendation of reviews Thank You
chair I mean my my view view is very
much along those lines I would actually
like to see this brought back to the
committee under having having the
applicants completed a housing needs
survey or at least bring this back as a
local need then it would comply with
policy I think unfortunately in this in
and the applicant hasn't had planning
advice that would enable us to conform
to a s10 which is why I got me a manual
out because I would very much like to
find a reason to go against the officers
recommendation and grant but I can't
find a reason that conforms with the
call strategy to be able to do this but
I would like as a message to be taken
back to the parish and the applicant
that this should come back under the
guise of a local of local needs and the
parish having done a very simple housing
needs survey which can be done free of
charge through Warwickshire Rural
Housing but on what is in put in front
of me this evening I'm I'm really sorry
I'm going to have to go with refused
councillor bombs I think I'd call them
social need
there's a need for this to happen
they've not had the proper advice
they've not gone about it the right way
hopefully they're listening and we can
move forward in the next point right
we've not had a proposition and I will
propose though we were it here is this
do I have a seconder caps married folks
doesn't beat me TP you do it nobody else
wants to speak all those in favour of
reviewers please show and against in
that case the committee resolves to
refuse application reference 19 slash 0
to 1 3 9 / ful moved final application
of the evening
thank you
okay this is found on page 45 your
agendas right let me just walk you
through this of course there are two
applications here so there are separate
applications that requires to have two
votes on it but I think we'll just have
one presentation if that's okay so these
are application reference 19/2 for 9 1 /
l bc and 19 / 2 7 0 0 / l bc for $97
dudley and 97 201 Ulster Road start Lee
respectively and after the repair of
boundary wall including replacement of
approximately 25 bricks and the
repointing of mortar joints demolition
of there's the second applications wall
and rebuilding repair of boundary wall
right something officer Kenny thank you
chair there were two applications before
members for repairs to a boundary wall
the location of the wall that is the
subject of both applications is
identified by the black dot it is such a
situated instantly and fronts on to the
austere road at its North End the wall
abut 97 oster Road which is listed great
- and itself then terminates at the site
entrance to the coach-house pub 101
after Road also known as the manor house
or Mountbatten house which is listed
great 2-star the wall is of
nineteenth-century dates and marks the
historic boundary of Mountbatten House
land in the ownership of Mountbatten
house formally extended northwards
behind the wall which has since been
redeveloped for housing the wall is of
red brick construction with blue brick
opens and declines in hide that stepped
intervals in a northerly direction the
first application concerns the section
of wall forming part of the West
boundary 297 Oster Road the application
side is identified by the red line
within the circle the image on the Left
identifies bricks of spalled which would
be either removed turned and then
reinstated or replaced to Marsh bricks
would only be replaced where their
condition was so deteriorated that they
could not be reused the image on the
right identified
the mortar joints that have weathered or
previously been pointed using cement
which are proposed to be repointed use
using lime mortar to match the existing
historic water the second application
concerns the entire length of the wall
the application site is identified by
the red line within the circle the
section of the wall highlighted in
purple is proposed to be dismantled and
then rebuilt to match the existing
design the section of wall not proposed
to be rebuilt would be subject to the
same scope of repairs as proposed by the
first application to either turn or
replace for bricks and to repoint where
required improved footings at the walls
base and piers to the walls rear
elevation would also be added the image
is now shown illustrate the walls
current condition it leans outwards over
the adjacent public foot way presenting
a health and safety issue whilst a
number of bricks have spalled
and mortar joints are empty where the
historic lime mortar is weathered away
it is therefore considered that the wall
is in need of repair to ensure its
long-term survival if left there is a
risk that its condition could continue
to decline the works proposed by the
first application would be consistent
with conservation principles of minimum
intervention and use of traditional
methods and materials the second
application proposes a higher level of
intervention but in this case it is
considered necessary due to the extent
of the lien and the walls proximity to
the highway the walls historic integrity
would be partly compromised by the
rebuilding but the scheme has been
designed to maintain the walls
appearance from the road this public
view demarcating the historic boundary
of Mountbatten house is what contributes
to the listed building special interest
in this case which therefore we would be
preserved in summary the condition of
the wall necessitates repair to ensure
its long-term survival methods of repair
have been carefully designed to preserve
character and the contribution of the
wall to the list of building
significance for this reason it is
recommended that consent be granted for
both applications brilliant
speaking Neil Adam please applicant
thank you so you have three minutes
remain seated for any questions at the
end
Thank You Sharon whilst these
applications are before you simply
because I'm a counselor on this occasion
the largest scale one is actually on
behalf of five households and comes off
the back of a turbulent and difficult
year attempting to coordinator and
mediate opinions views technicalities
and very high emotions of residents who
found themselves a very unfortunate and
complicated position where a wall that
four of them didn't realize they owned
has now been determined to be listed and
thus leaving will cost it than it maybe
could have been also to be noted is that
colloquially and in residents memory the
wall is regardless having always been in
that condition that we currently see it
and it doesn't actually pose it any
danger
the second smaller application
represents my personal responsibilities
based on the structural engineers report
and was submitted in advance of the
larger plan for more substantial and
coordinated work whilst I've decided to
leave this more application wide to
cover my own responsibilities should the
situation change a lot you heard is that
it will never be required as the larger
scale work will be carried out in
preference notwithstanding all the
previously mentioned trials and
tribulations with a great deal of effort
from myself an enormous amount of help
from officers and the legal department
we now find ourselves in a position
where we have accord amongst the
residents and a proposal status
satisfies both the heritage officers and
health and safety requirements are
therefore kind ask members to accept the
offices report and grab approval of the
proposal so that the residents can move
forward and resolve an already stressful
and costly predicament and move forward
with their lives in the new year thank
you you've had a bit of a headache with
this one to be honest any questions from
the committee
no thank you very much then right points
of clarification no debate callous
rather
this seems fairly simple thank you very
much all those in favor please show all
those in favor then please